From movie monster to horror icon, M3GAN could
be the monstrous voice of a new generation.
New horror villains drop all the time, and
compelling characters like "Malignant's"
Gabriel and "The Babadook's" titular entity
show that filmmakers have no shortage of
imagination when it comes to creating
visually impressive villains. Still,
apart from the Babadook's unlikely
stint as a meme-worthy LGBTQ+ icon,
most horror monsters have a long way to go
before they really reach the status of an "icon."
"Babadook dook DOOK"
"M3GAN," on the other hand, was a different
beast from the point that the first trailer
dropped. When the film itself turned out to be
even more entertaining than the doll's dance
moves in the promotional material, it was clear
that Gen Z has received its first horror icon.
Megan the killer friend-bot is sassy, smart,
funny, infinitely meme-able, and ... relatable,
somehow. What's more, her potential to become
a genre mainstay is vast, and everyone involved
knows it. Universal was already interested in
a "M3GAN" sequel before the movie premiered,
and after a successful $30 million debut,
the age of "M3GAN" has officially just begun.
"You should probably run."
While murder clowns and axe killers are
just as terrifying to younger generations
as they are to any other cohort of
people, Gen Z is notably the first
truly digital generation that has never
known a world without the internet. Thus,
your average Gen Zer is likely far more personally
familiar with advanced technology than they are
with circuses or wood-cutting implements.
Right away, that's a point for "M3GAN,"
whose horror and humor are technology-based.
There's also the fact that the creepy doll's
very nature as a go-getter who values its
loved ones and has an extremely practical,
though murderous, approach to problem-solving
is quite close to Gen Z's core values.
Roberta Katz of Stanford University
describes Gen Z thoughtfully,
"...a typical Gen Zer is a self-driver who
deeply cares about others, strives for a
diverse community, is highly collaborative
and social, values flexibility, relevance,
authenticity and non-hierarchical leadership,
and, while dismayed about inherited issues like
climate change, has a pragmatic attitude about the
work that has to be done to address those issues."
Of course, as Variety notes, a clever, shrewd
marketing strategy that went hard at Tiktok
and Twitter memeability played a part in
giving "M3GAN" its deserved horror queen
crown. Going viral has translated into
both cultural status and box-office love.
It's almost certain that a torrent of imitators
will attempt to recreate "M3GAN's" success with
their own takes on memeable, marketable horror
that guns for viral attention in hopes of creating
horror icons of their own. Unfortunately, it's
also pretty likely that things won't be that easy.
A horror icon like the M3gan robot is lightning in
a bottle — rare and tough to replicate, even when
all the ingredients are clearly visible. Besides,
since "M3GAN" will likely occupy the collective "
new horror icon" headspace for the immediate
future, there's not much room for newcomers.
As such, it may be more interesting to
view "M3GAN" as the spearhead of a general
horror trend that's been emerging in recent
years and only seems to be growing stronger.
Horror has always been at its strongest
when it draws from familiar experience,
and recent movies have been heavily inspired
by experiences that are far more inherently
familiar to Gen Z than immortal machete men
stalking summer camps can ever hope to be.
From "Candyman" to "Get Out," horror has always
been excellent at tackling social and cultural
affairs. Now that more and more Gen Z filmmakers
are hitting their horror stride, the focus has
simply shifted to what they know well, shedding
the pre-online world of their predecessors in the
process. This will no doubt result in countless
amazing horror films and icons in the future.